what makes an actor hate their own movie
why Would You Backtrack on your big
break what does it take to make Ed
Harris cry you asked and we've got the
answers Four Christmases is a 2004
comedy film about a couple who are
forced to visit the relatives at
Christmas after their flight out of the
country is canceled played by Vince
Vaughn and Reese Witherspoon the pair
soon learn a number of surprising
secrets about each other and themselves
you know classic rom-com stuff when it
came time to promote the movie however
only Witherspoon was present in
interviews and press events reports at
the time suggested that Vaughn had
purposely scheduled other work to clash
with the promotion of Four Christmases
as a way of getting out of having to
appear alongside his co-star Vaughn
didn't even attend the film's premiere
this seemingly arose out of a conflict
between the two actors that had
coalesced on set as it turned out
certain scenes were cut from the movie
because Vaughn and Witherspoon refused
to spend time together
2004's Hellboy came several years before
the big boom in comic book adaptations
but was still successful enough to
justify a sequel in 2008 and a reboot of
the franchise in 2019. directed by
Guillermo del Toro and based on the Dark
Horse Comics character the film stars
Ron Perlman as the titular half demon
hero who fights monsters alongside FBI
agent Johnny Myers and the amphibious
humanoid Abe Sapien though played by
Doug Jones Abe is voiced by Frasier star
David Hyde Pierce who refused to be
credited for his work Pierce was
reportedly hired for the role because he
was a more recognizable name but the
actor did not want to take away from
Jones physical performance in an
interview with io9 Jones confirmed that
pierce refused any credit for his voice
work and did not do any promotional work
on the movie all because he wanted his
co-star to take credit for the part for
the sequel Hellboy 2 the Golden Army Abe
was portrayed completely by Jones who
has also provided the voice for the
character in an animated TV spin-off at
one point in time Lindsay Lohan was the
most in-demand child star in the world
later however she endured a number of
career difficulties and nowadays she
rarely appears in any major projects on
film or television perhaps it was that
lack of work that drove her towards the
2013 Paul Schroeder film The Canyons in
this movie lowen stars alongside adult
film actor James Dean as a woman in a
relationship with an abusive partner
despite Landing poorly with critics and
fans lowen's performance in the canyons
did attract some praise but her work
didn't seem to extend to helping promote
the film lambasting the actor in public
Schroeder claimed that she refused to do
any promotional work for the Canyons
even though he had moved Premiere dates
and locations to better suit her
schedule the filmmaker was even angrier
considering that he felt he had given
low end multiple Second Chances
throughout filming during which she had
often proved unreliable and you know the
new Lindsay didn't show up right the old
Lindsay showed up Paul Thomas Anderson
released Boogie Nights in 1997 a movie
that charts the rise and fall of the
American pornographic industry during
the 70s and 80s the movie was a huge hit
when it was released enjoying a
successful box office run and receiving
widespread praise from both the audience
and critics bogey knights was also
nominated for a number of oscars
including best supporting actor and
actress nods for Burt Reynolds and
Julianne Moore but one person who wasn't
happy with the film was Reynolds himself
who despite putting in one of the best
performances of his career regretted
filming it so much that he fired his
agent in the aftermath Reynolds this day
is for Boogie Nights as well as his
Frosty relationship with Anderson meant
that he performed basically no
promotional work for the film this meant
refusing to campaign for his Oscar which
co-star Mark Wahlberg later said may
have cost him the award based on the
1996 novel Push by American Author
Sapphire precious is a 2009 film
directed by Lee Daniels this story
follows a troubled young girl Clarice
Jones who has recently become pregnant
illiterate in facing few life prospects
she is encouraged to enroll in an
alternative school that could give her a
second chance a against the wishes of
her unemployed mother Mary the film won
critical Acclaim upon its release with
Gabourey Sidibe and Monique receiving
particular praise for their performances
as Clarice and Mary respectively each
received a number of high-profile Award
nominations with Monique finally taking
home an Academy Award for her role
famously however she did not do any
campaigning on the awards circuit ahead
of the Oscars and was unwilling to
travel in order to promote the film
ahead of its release Monique later
claimed this was so that she could spend
more time with her family however she
also revealed she was paid just fifty
thousand dollars for her role in the
film and felt she should have been
compensated more to do extra work
promoting precious
following the success of the 2010 black
comedy kick ass a sequel was quickly put
into development released in 2013
Kick-Ass 2 saw the original movie's cast
joined by comedy icon Jim Carrey who
played Colonel Stars in Stripes oh
we try to have fun
otherwise
what's the point
Carrie's character is a former Mafia
member who worked with the villains in
the first film but was never shown on
screen by the time Kick-Ass 2 takes
place he has renounced his previous
criminal life and now operates the
Vigilante group Justice forever just two
months before the release of Kick-Ass 2
Carrie revealed that he would not take
any part in publicity for the movie he
cited concerns about violence in the
film especially admits the Sandy Hook
Elementary School shooting tweeting I
did kick ass a month before Sandy Hook
and now in all good conscience I cannot
support that level of violence the
original comic books creator Mark Miller
later pointed out that the movie's
violent nature had been very clear from
the start in a statement he said a movie
called Kick-Ass 2 really has to do what
it says on the tent in the early days of
the MCU Edward Norton played Bruce
Banner in The Incredible Hulk the film
charts the origin of the Hulk as the
military attempts to use him to develop
a group of super soldiers arguably one
of the most lackluster movies in the MCU
The Incredible Hulk faced a mixed
critical reception and didn't perform
too well at the box office although it
was seen as a significant upgrade
compared to the 2003 film by all
accounts production on the Incredible
Hulk did not go smoothly reports suggest
that Norton was difficult to work with
questioning the direction of the film
and demanding frequent rewrites to the
script when it came time to publicize
the release the actor was notably absent
wildfellow star live Tyler and director
Louis La Terrier completed a number of
press interviews these factors later led
to Norton being replaced as Hulk in the
MCU with Mark Ruffalo eventually taking
over the role now might be a really good
time for you to get angry
that's my secret cat
[Music]
I'm always angry
Marvel Studios Ed Kevin feige later said
in a statement our decision is
definitely not one based on monetary
factors but instead rooted in the need
for an actor who embodies the creativity
and collaborative Spirit of her other
talented cast members the counselor was
a 2013 crime Thriller that had high
expectations especially considering it
was directed by Ridley Scott and
featured a truly stacked cast the movie
follows a criminal Texan lawyer who
becomes embroiled in the illegal drug
trade and faces dire consequences when a
cartel deal goes bad it was one of
Cameron Diaz's final films before her
acting Hiatus and failed to perform
suffering both mediocre reviews and a
disappointing box office return the
reason behind yaza's refusal to do any
promotional work for the counselor
apparently comes down to the fact that
she was forced to redub all of her lines
the actor had reportedly portrayed her
character with a strong Bajan accent
only for Studio Executives to push back
and force her to re-record all of her
dialogue Diaz was obviously less than
impressed with this and her unhappiness
with the way things turned out likely
contributed to her exit from the movie's
publicity tour James Cameron's 1989
sci-fi thriller the abyss follows a team
of scientists to investigate a sunken
nuclear submarine and discover something
sinister living under the water despite
being one of Cameron's least successful
movies at the box office the abyss was
still something of a hit with and later
won an Academy Award for best visual
effects by all accounts production on
the abyss was difficult with Cameron
putting his actors through various
ordeals to get the footage he needed
speaking to the Los Angeles Times Ed
Harris liking the treatment of the cast
to the experiences of soldiers in
Vietnam in various reports he also spoke
about one instance in which he burst
into tears on the drive home after
particularly bad day of filming Harris
eventually decided that he would refuse
to speak about the abyss after it hit
Cinema screens essentially disavowing it
in public
in 2012 to commemorate the 50th
anniversary of the release of Dr No MGM
released a special DVD box set
containing every entry in the James Bond
series up to that point an important
indication in the franchise's history
the release was accompanied by a
significant marketing campaign that
included former Bond actors promoting
the box set Sean Connery however was
notably absent from the publicity push
Connery has always had something of a
rough relationship with the James Bond
franchise despite delivering arguably
the iconic iteration of the legendary
spy notably he has appeared in many of
the very best entries in the franchise
such as From Russia with Love and
Goldfinger Bond
[Music]
Connery's agent explained that he had
retired and did not want to make further
public appearances but reports at the
time suggested that he had been
underpaid for his performances in the
series
the sound of music is a much-loved
musical directed by Robert Wise in 1965.
the movie stars Julie Andrews and
Christopher Plummer alongside a cast of
children and a story about a nun who
goes to look after the children of a
widowed former naval officer it won
numerous Awards when it was released and
became a box office sensation grossing
more than 150 million dollars despite
its huge success in lasting appeal
plumber actually hated The Sound of
Music he had a habit of not even
referring to the film by its actual
title instead calling it The Sound of
mucus and S M as well as occasionally
just mentioning it as the movie speaking
in more recent years Plummer revealed
that he was simply bored of the
character and didn't find the subject
matter interesting in an interview with
The Hollywood Reporter he said it was so
awful and sentimental and gooey you had
to work terribly hard to try and Infuse
some minuscule bit of humor into it he
also refused to attend many of the
film's anniversary events and was
notably absent from promotional videos
in which the rest of the cast appeared
Savage Steve Holland's 1985 movie better
off dead stars John Cusack as Lane Meyer
a high school student who repeatedly
tries to end his own life after his
girlfriend breaks up with him when his
inept attempts at suicide caused more
embarrassment for the youngster he
attempts to win back his love by
competing in a skiing competition while
better off dead was neither popular nor
lucrative at the time it has become
something of a cult film in the years
since Cusack has never hidden his
disdain for the movie however according
to Holland the actor walked out of a
screening of better off dead and refused
to work with him following the
completion of their subsequent movie One
Crazy Summer Cusack told Holland that he
hated better off dead and chose to
promote neither that movie nor One Crazy
Summer
foreign